and for more on corporate tax dodgers
and the trouble with legal loopholes
were joined by too much type I director
of the handbook Institute of
International Economics first of all
please tell us what exactly are we
talking about are these companies
breaking any laws that's a good question
and the answer is definitely no I mean
managers are not doing loss it's always
policymakers that have done these laws
and that have made it possible to avoid
becoming text so it's I think part of a
dual model discussion now just to blame
the managers they have to do so because
as we have just seen they have to follow
the interests of the owners the
stakeholders as well and usually you
just had a very interesting very
important thing of course those new
polls they didn't grow on trees they
were created by authorities within
countries in order to create an
incentive for companies to do business
there so why should they close these
loopholes at all yeah that's a good
question because firstly I understand
that there is a pressure to close these
policies of tax avoidance but on the
other hand we have to probably think
about mode basically why are we taxing
firms and what's the argument of taxing
firms that are producing chops oh so the
alternative it was say let's no longer
tax them no but probably you could tax
the money when it leaves a company when
it is somehow becomes profit for the
owners for the shareholders and not as
long as it stays within the firm to tax
money actually that the law has been
changed this way years ago just to
attract be attractive to attract firms
now the EU has recently agreed to crack
down on tax dodgers by lifting bank
secrecy could a similar approach also
help close the gap of corporate tax tax
dodgers yes absolutely and i think this
is the right way to go that you have if
you have a low you have to execute the
law of course and if you want to do it
and you have to do
so this is a good way to follow the
things you want to do now the European
Union is faced right now at the moment
with many their problems and not all of
them are man-made the most recent one
has been caused by weeks of heavy rain
of course which of course some of the
worst flooding in decades in southern
and eastern Germany we have some
pictures here but also in Austria and
the Czech Republic residents have to be
evacuated emergency services are working
around the clock to prevent more dams
from breaking of the flooding is taking
on historic proportions it's actually
worse than the last one back in 2002
which caused economic damage of more
than 11 billion euros there's a lot of
money what are we're faced with now I'm
afraid that the damage will be similar
as 10 years ago because on a regional
scale this is really a disaster if you
cannot cross bridges then you cannot go
to work and so the firm's have to shut
down for a while and so as is the case
with folks back in Saxony right now so
this will be damaged at least at the
short run in the short run so in terms
of revenue damage will it be a real
problem for these country cycles here
for the short run yes but the experience
shows from earlier cases that in the
medium and long run and also from a
macro economic perspectives the damages
are rather low due to the fact that the
costs of someone is the earning of the
other one so it is kind of a cynical
consequence of economics that in a long
run even if it's a damage for
individuals for the economy as a whole
it's not that severe it just shows
there's a bright side to everything just
briefly perhaps if you could what does
the the catastrophe our the floodings do
to Europe which is already struggling
with its eurozone debt crisis I don't
think that it has an impact on these
issues okay too much papa thank you very
much for joining us today